having the right actor or actress as an
integral aspect of any successful TV
show sometimes these stars are so
important that the show conquer one
without them here are some major TV
shows such as couldn't recover from the
last and replacement of a leading actor
Sleepy Hollow Fox's supernatural police
drama was always a little bit different
than other cop shows the starters one of
his main characters was Ichabod Crane
from Washington Irving's short story The
Legend of Sleepy Hollow who comes back
to life in the present day after having
died 200 years or so prior crane that
helps fight supernatural menaces
alongside police lieutenant Abbie Mills
over three seasons a Sleepy Hollow
settled into its role as a quirky police
procedural and then it did the
unthinkable
Abbie died and actress Nicole bihari
left the series despite a steep loss of
viewers from season 1 to season 3 Sleepy
Hollow returned for a fourth season with
Alta be a kebab was now partnered with a
homeland security agent named Diana
Thomas the cast reboots it into Sleepy
Hollow any favors though the show fell
even further in the ratings and was soon
cancelled after seven seasons of the hit
Fox sitcom actor Topher Grace decided to
leave that 70 show in order to more
fiercely pursue his blossoming film
career Erik wasn't the only member of
the gang who left Kelso played by the
show's other biggest star Ashton Kutcher
also left the show although could just
stuck around for a few episodes in
season 8 to explain his character's
departure to replace two very big holes
in it's cast producers hired just one
actor MADtv veteran Josh Meyers his
character Randy gets the job at Hyde's
record store and has a brief
relationship with Donna Eric's old
girlfriend neither Randy nor Myers had
much time to mesh to the ensemble the
decimated cast may have contributed to
the show's diminish popularity and
inevitable ending the eighth season of
the seventy show would be us last
although grace and Kutcher would both
come back to say goodbye for the finale
we never run out of things to talk about
yeah you burn out to be down here you
guys it's almost midnight mrs. farmers
pouring the champagne step by step was
an ABC sitcom about Carol Anne Frank
Lambert two single parents who bring
their families together in addition to
all their kids Frank's nephew Cody lived
in a van outside the house
Cody was a good-natured airheaded
California dude basically a sitcom
version of Ted from Bill and Ted's
Excellent Adventure affable and
enthusiastic acting by Sasha Mitchell
made the character of fan favorites but
in 1995 when Mitchell was arrested for
spousal assaults he was convicted later
that year and sentenced to three years
of probation and spousal abuse
counseling Mitchell wound up behind bars
for violating his parole and reportedly
attacked his wife again at the beginning
of the sixth season of step by step Cody
was gone replaced by jean-luc a heavily
accented hairdresser colleague of
Carol's playing John Lucas Bronson
Pinchot best known for playing the
excitable heavily accented bulky on
perfect strangers and the excitable
heavily accented Serge in Beverly Hills
Cop the new cast Edition didn't work at
ABC cancelled step by step at the end of
the season the show that moved to CBS
for a final year without Pinchot after
the first season of the facts of life
the number of main characters was cut
from ten to just five Eastland boarding
school House mother mrs. garrets and
four female students after those four
graduated in the fourth season mrs.
Garrett opened a gourmet shop and hired
her former students and after season
seven mrs. Garrett herself Charlotte Rae
left the show she thought it was time to
move on later telling Entertainment
Weekly that the show could continue on
without her but producers loved the
show's dynamic of a wise older woman
doling out advice to young women so they
created the role of mrs. Garrett's
sister Beverly Ann
however there were placement didn't
quite work and by the ninth season the
facts of life was and ceremoniously
canceled American Idol has created a
number of stars such as Kelly Clarkson
Jennifer Hudson Adam Lambert and of
course Simon Cowell audiences couldn't
get enough of the judge who was often
brutally and hilariously honest with
contestants okay
best singer in America oh yeah right I
can honestly say you want worse sickness
in America Cowell was the biggest star
of the series which was the most-watched
show on TV for an impress a dented eight
straight seasons but in 2010 after nine
seasons he moved on in part to develop
the American version of his British
talent series The X Factor idol
producers had a hard time replacing
Cowell as well as fellow original judge
Paula Abdul the idol judges tables were
lots of stars take a stab at it but
actual singers just couldn't fill the
void left by the music industry guy who
criticized the singers by the time Fox
pulled the plug on American Idol in 2016
it has slipped out at the top 20 most
viewed shows maybe with mistake News
Radio NBC's critically acclaimed but
Lowe watched Comedy had no plans to
replace one of its characters and the
best-known star but tragedy for sir
producers hand between the show's fourth
and fifth season star Phil Hartman was
shot to death by his troubled wife it
was a horrific crime and a devastating
loss to the show but in order to
complete enough episodes to sell the
show into syndication News Radio was
picked up for another season anyway in
the season premiere it was explained
that Hartman's character pompous radio
newsreader bill McNeal
died of a sudden heart attack replacing
him at the newsreaders desk was a new
character max Lewis weird insecure and
holy and qualified for the position max
was portrayed by Harmons friends and
Saturday Night Live co-star Jon Lovitz
while Lovitz has a great comic actor he
just couldn't overcome the sadness
looming over News Radio loved its first
season would be the show's last for the
Fox television adaptation of Lethal
Weapon Klain Crawford took over for Mel
Gibson as loose cannon Martin Briggs and
if unset reports published by Variety
are any indication Crawford was even
harder to control than his character in
an episode he directed a special effects
explosion went awry sending a piece of
debris at co-star Damon Wayans when
Wayans complained
Crawford referred to his co-star as a
crybaby another time he reportedly
screamed and swore at a group of
children who wandered near on yet
another occasion he reportedly proved so
hard to work with that a director walked
off the set in the middle of a shoot in
May 2018 after two seasons producers
eliminated what they thought was the
root cause of the show's problems and
fired
Crawford they wish to find somebody to
replace them and quickly hired Seann
William Scott's to play Wesley Cole a
new partner for detective Roger Murtaugh
Scott couldn't save the show however all
that tension didn't totally dissipate
with Wayans announcing that he planned
to lead this series in the middle of the
season Fox decided to watch their hands
up the whole thing in May 2019 and
canceled Lethal Weapon from 1998 to 2007
Kevin James and Leah Remini sat on the
popular CBS sitcom King of Queens James
would go on to star in a string of
movies like grown-ups and paul blart
mall cop but in 2016 he returned to the
weekly CBS sitcom grind with Kevin can
wait
James portrayed Kevin Gable a family man
who has to delay were tyring from his
police job due to family and money
issues playing opposite James was Erin
Hayes as Kevin's wife Donna Gable
at least that's how it was for the first
season Kevin can wait producers revamped
the show for season two they killed off
Donna gable and fired Hayes James
explained the decision to the New York
Daily News by saying we were literally
just running out of ideas they also
brought in a new face who was really a
familiar face surprisingly Leah Remini
joined Kevin can wait as Kevin's
business partner Vanessa
however the nostalgically booting
couldn't overcome the weird behind the
scenes shaker and ratings actually
dropped in season two after the
conclusion of the sitcom second
ill-fated season CBS didn't waits to
cancel Kevin an in-sample drama with a
culturally diverse cast set in and often
surreal rural Alaska northern exposure
was radically different from most other
shows on television Rob Morrow starred
as dr. Joel fishmen a snobby New York
City doctor who heads north to service a
tiny town of Sicily Northern Exposure
was a big hit reaching the top 20 in the
ratings and earning four straight Emmy
nominations for Outstanding Drama Series
and winning the prize in 1992 but
Fleischmann's desire to leave Alaska
never faded Amaro wanted to bounce -
halfway through the show's sixth season
Morrow fled Northern Exposure reportedly
to pursue new acting challenges and a
movie career replacing him was a new
precision dr. Philip Capra portrayed by
Paul Provenza a respected stand-up
comedian who had little acting
experience apart from his work on
sitcoms
that an experience seems to have showed
after just half a season with Provenza
at the helm the network cancelled
northern exposure the high
called sitcom head of the class debuted
on ABC in 1986 it explored the
relationships between a diverse group of
highly advanced Manhattan students and
the history teacher Charlie Moore played
by howard hesseman a big part of white
head of the class worked is that it
wasn't Samba focused the various kids
had personal and academic problems and
mr. Moore help them sort things out
Esmond portrayed more with
understatements and subtlety letting his
younger co-stars take center stage
however the actor hated head of the
class in 1989 he told her a rapport so
that he thought the show didn't have
much worth he said we're not doing the
show that I was led to believe I do and
it's difficult for me to get off that
unsurprisingly hesseman left a show in
1990 in his place for Scottish comedian
Billy Connolly at a teacher named Billy
McGregor all of a sudden show about high
school kids problems was a show about
wacky mr. McGregor ABC seemed to realize
that too in 1991 the network cancelled
head of the class and quickly ordered up
a new show called Billy Connolly
continued to play McGregor who was now
living as a boarder and a California
single mother's house community never
had a huge audience during his five-year
run on NBC nevertheless NBC kept
renewing the critically acclaimed comedy
about the desperate people who
compromised a Colorado community college
study group that loyalty remained even
after increasing difficulties of
community crater and showrunner Dan
Harmon who was fired and then rehired
however five seasons was ultimately
NBC's limit leaving Internet giant Yahoo
to step in and renew community for a
sixth season original regulars Joel
McHale Gillian Jacobs Danny Pudi
Ken Jeong and Alison Brie followed the
series a yahoo but the show would have
been losing cast members and kept losing
them as a transition to streaming Chevy
Chase at Donald Glover and Avett Nicole
Brown were not part of the regular cast
of communities six season new actors
were added but the band-aid casting just
didn't work and there was no seventh
season of community not enough people
tuned in and the show didn't generate as
much advertising revenue as Yahoo had
hoped in fact the revenue was so small
that it effectively led to the complete
shutdown of Yahoo screen Yahoo's CFO Ken
Goldman said
earnings call that the company lost 42
million dollars because of community and
it's two other original series scrubs a
dramedy about medical interns
desperately trying to figure out what
they were doing as they worked in a
hospital
what's a critically acclaimed Emmy
nominated hit over its first few seasons
on NBC the network finally dropped
scrubs after seven seasons in 2008 but
got picked up by ABC to finish things
off with an eighth season the show's
writers and cast prepared a true series
finale to cap off those episodes only
for ABC to unexpectedly renew this
series for season nine by that point
however stars like Braff was ready to
move on to other things
so the show was retooled and rebooted no
longer taking place at a teaching
hospital but at a medical school
familiar doctors were now teachers
instead of active surgeons Braff moved
to the background and the new narrator
and center of the show became dr. Lucy
Bennett ultimately the big changes were
too much to take and the ninth season of
scrubs was its last check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]